to get some more on what we can expect
the leadership candidates to perhaps do
um when it comes to the cost living
crisis i'm joined by the supporter of
rich united teresa villas this morning
twitter village thank you so much for
coming in this morning so you will have
seen the numbers that have come out from
cornwall insight yesterday richard nike
said he's promising hundreds of pounds
more is that enough
he's rishi's determined if his prime
minister do as as much as he can to help
people through what is a a crisis around
the world with energy bills i mean sadly
no government
can insulate everyone from all these
costs but richie certainly recognizes
that we need to do more and he's already
said
we should suspend that on energy bills
he was already the chancellor
responsible for the 37 billion package
but uh yes further payments are likely
to be needed yeah and and so to what it
costs will that be how much more do you
think people can actually expect to to
get because there are a similar point
this morning that the shortfall that
many will have when the energy price
goes up is some sixteen hundred pounds
so there's gonna be a lot more money
needed isn't there
it's already the case that around eight
million households are going to get 1200
pounds under the package which is
already put in place in his former role
as chancellor
i think we need to wait and see what the
regulator comes out with in terms of the
energy price cap but i know that uh
rishi believes clearly that we do need
to do more to help yeah i mean wait
until the 26th of august you know there
are calls
for rishi and feliz and for boris
johnson and the chancellor perhaps to
sit around the table and try and work
something out now because it's anxiety
that people are dealing with isn't it
they don't know what their bills are
going to be in a few weeks time and
that's really making people feel very
worried indeed
inevitably this is this is hitting
virtually everyone and i want people to
be reassured that
you know these payments the the big
package the 37 billion package is
starting to be delivered
to people's bank accounts now
um and those energy discounts you know
will be kicking in from from october and
rishi if he wins has said that this vat
suspension will apply as soon as
possible so help is on the way but i
think it is important to recognize that
we will need to do more i mean the
problem with that fat suspension is that
rishi sunlight himself said back in
february it would disproportionately
benefit the wealthy i mean does he
regret saying that now now that he's
saying that's his big idea
he's been pragmatic on this this is this
is a change that could be introduced
right away
um and it's still more targeted than
some of the you know the very big tax
cuts for higher earners
that um his opponent wants to introduce
instead i mean one of the big plans that
we heard from siren davey uh just
recently was to to not bring the price
cap in at all and make the energy
companies absorb the cost is that an
idea that michigan would be in favor of
well he's already been responsible for
additional taxation on
on the big oil companies
and i'm sure looking at
these masses see if the oil and energy
companies can contribute more
is is it something that we should
seriously consider i think it is
important to make ensure that um
the tax system still encourages those
companies to invest because of course
that's crucial for our energy security
in the future so they're not paying
enough in tax either because there's a
reporting this morning there's going to
be a meeting held between uh the
chancellor and the business actually
quality quality and earnings of highway
with those big energy companies to look
at that windfall tax to see whether the
loopholes that risky put in to ensure
investment can actually be taken out to
make sure that we get more revenue from
them
well the big oil companies are already
subjected to
additional taxation additional
corporation tax and
the additional taxation announced by by
rishi previously but yes we do need to
look at
um the huge levels of corporate income
which are being experienced at the
moment to see if those companies can
play a part in
in further help for their customers who
are suffering i mean morally do you
think they are paying enough taxes and
do you think that the fact that they are
reaping so much in revenue at this time
this particular time in history is that
right how should families be feeling
about that do you think
well we've already intervened to ensure
that the big oil companies do pay more
tax i i think we need to take care that
we don't disincentivize vital investment
which can which is the long-term
solution to getting energy costs down
and ensuring our energy security but but
yes of course we need to take seriously
whether
you know the the power companies the
energy companies
could play a bigger part in helping
their customers at what is an incredibly
difficult time
i mean apart from maybe taxing them or
looking at their revenues what other
parts do you think they could play in
helping in helping customers
well certainly they they should be doing
all they can to ensure their customers
on like are getting the best rate that
their understanding about people who
have have difficulties paying
um right this idea of a social tariff so
it really is as low as possible i think
the idea may even be that that tariff is
slightly subsidized to make sure that
the people on the lowest income do not
get hit by these huge risers
it's already the case that everyone's
going to be getting discounts on their
energy bill thanks to the 37 billion
package which which is already in place
okay let's just focus a little bit on
the campaign um for a leadership by
rishi soonech now chris skidmore was a
risky next supporter he's now switched
over to liz trust i mean what does that
tell us about the way that rishi is is
cutting through with people
inevitably mps changed their minds
during this con these contests that's
why he's not hearing the right things
and is he i mean that's correctly
because what's led him to change his
mind it's not that she's had a terrible
campaign i mean
not at all rishi has the right plan for
the economy we're heading into
a really serious situation as a country
and
our first priority has to be to be to
tackle inflation rishi is a person with
a plan to do that that's why i'm backing
him and that's you know i talk every day
to conservative party members he's got a
huge amount of support and he's got the
right plan for our economy maybe we
should talk more to chris goodman let's
look at the latest polling on rishi
versus liz trusting we can bring up here
22 i mean that is a huge gap this is the
most recent that we have and that gap
just seems to be widening so you're
talking to members every day i guess you
didn't speak to mr skidmore because he's
changed his mind
as i say mps change their minds in these
contests all the time it's a routine
part of every conservative leadership
election contest there's ever been but
richie had a tremendously good hustings
in darlington last night on
on in the sky hustings he won over that
audience he's getting a tremendous
reception on the ground he's campaigning
to win okay i'm glad you brought up the
hustling last night so we have a clip i
want to play to you from the hustings
last night
here he is everybody soon like he said
last night um
oh let's have a listen to it sorry i'm
told that we do actually have it let's
have a listen but it's also why i want
to stand up to this lefty woke culture
that seems to want to cancel our
histories our values and our women
women to lefty woke culture think
something that was going to take us out
of rabbit hole but this idea of standing
up for our women does that sit right
with you what's he talking about there
standing up for our our women what is
this our women that he's talking about
i think he's he's just taking on this
this debate about you know biological
sex we've got to respect that a woman is
a woman and women only spaces need to be
defended women's rights were hard won
over
over many years and they shouldn't be
jeopardized so you're very happy with
that kind of language even though it
might be alienating to some some parts
of the constituency we need to ensure
that you know everyone is respected
their their their approach is is
respected
but it is the case that women support
women only spaces
uh should be should be protected i mean
the sky leadership debate where he did
you say win over the crowd he did also
say that he um abstain from every major
vote on abortion because he wasn't
around him he doesn't seem much like an
ally of women if he's not voting in
abortion debates but he's clear that he
supports the current law on abortion
i should show you one more thing around
about this issue this is not supposed to
do but i do want to get your um
perspective on it this has come up on a
nhs wales website um this is a website
about um periods and the women and girls
have been removed and it's about young
people who bleed i mean your reaction to
that that women and girls are being
removed from a
from a website that is providing
information about periods
uh well i i think it's wrong to remove
terms like women and girls from from
these kinds of websites i i i don't
think that um
you know the reference to young people
who bleed is
is appropriate we can't be in a
situation where terms like women mother
girls are removed from our discourse i
mean you recognize the fact that the
idea is to be as inclusive as possible
what are your concerns about having
those words kind of
those words removed as we're seeing in
many instances
well i think it just doesn't reflect
reality you know we need to
um it's vitally important that we
address issues around for example the
menopause around motherhood and that
means you know using using appropriate
terminology
you know including female women uh
mother and these kind of terms okay
teresa villas support richland we
appreciate it time thank you very much
for being with us thank you